who loves mark wahlberg i do
well mark is about to hit me
drew loves her he's about to hit the big
screen again in a movie called father
stew which is an inspirational story
about a catholic priest and this has
been a passion project for mark and now
entertainment tonight reports mark
transformed himself for the movie he
gained 30 pounds in six weeks you guys
oh i could do that yeah i'm like uh how
do you do it by going to lunch with drew
and i that's how he did it we could do
that but no here's really how he did it
he um worked up an appetite by lifting
weights in the morning oh i don't do
that i don't do that either and then
this is what he ate he he booked up on a
dozen eggs a dozen strips of bacon
that's a lot two baked potatoes a steak
two bowls of white rice and a full glass
of olive oil
if they came to you though because and
said here's the great part it's the part
of a lifetime but you have to put on 30
pounds are you in
i mean i can do that so easily that is
like that is not a big deal for me i've
had two kids and i'm 47. so that 30
pounds
is not a challenge
like a sharp hey that pouch fills up
real fast yeah sharpie
well everything sounded so good that he
ate except for that big glass of
glass with olive oil uh
i could not do don't don't tell me
you're gonna oh god
no
oh my god
[Applause]
i can't even think about it
[Applause]
i can't do it i can't do it
oh my god that is that is that's the
grossest thing we've had at the desk um
but i will say i
love mark wahlberg so much
beyond
next a wedding conundrum this comes to
us from usa today's advice column a
soon-to-be bride writes that she and her
fiance are planning an october wedding
because they wanted to do it in the
halloween
style they're both going to wear black
but it turns out the bride's mom
not pleased
her father just wants her to be happy
but her mom is an old-school traditional
catholic and is like basically saying
like i don't know if i can come to this
wedding if you do it this way i might
have to boycott if you wear the black
wedding dress that you're planning on
and so the bride is asking is is she
wrong oh i'll tell you right now the mom
is wrong you're wrong it's not your
wedding
do you
do would you have children so that they
can just live your life no you haven't
seen the end of their life so if she
wants a freaky halloween wedding trick
or treat honey let her have it
um i actually would like to say to the
mom i uh maybe we let our daughters pull
a 492 and just be free
and do their own thing
um
and um i just also want to say to the
mom that i don't just mean that as like
a pithy metaphor so this costume is on
order right now because this is what my
daughter wants to wear to her birthday
um and if you'll look here is the
invitation that she designed oh my gosh
so um i had to have debates with frankie
about what level of fear i was going to
instill in other parents so
492
stay lobby
[Music]
you